I like being fashionably late to the
party what can I say but thank you for
your patience waiting for this review
but here I am here you are let's review
it
[Music]
submission of possible dead reckoning is
the seventh the first half of the
seventh the sixth and a half part one of
the seventh Mission Impossible movie
once again starring Tom Cruise who
are you ready for it you're not is older
than Jon Voight was in the original
Mission Impossible movie right so once
again he's going after baddies the
government's going after him because
they think he's a baddie and here we go
new Mission Impossible movie part one
now the mission impossible cast list is
absolutely it's exponentially growing we
have returning cast members returning
crew returning friends returning allies
and new ones of the newcomers Haley
Atwell I thought she was fantastic I
thought she had great chemistry with Tom
Cruise the Mission Impossible movies
have generally done good on that Rebecca
Ferguson she's another one returning
cast member also that's just one of my
favorites in the franchise Haley Atwell
was no exception of that I thought she
was fantastic a lot of people other than
you know like Simon Peg and Ving Rhames
they're his allies forever a lot of the
other folks out there on the battlefield
with Ethan Hunt could run into that
enemy if my enemy kind of scenario I
enjoy it when a movie flirts with that
also pong clementiff who plays mantis in
the Guardians of the Galaxy movies I
don't want to give a comic book movie
comparison because it kind of feels like
low hanging fruit she is in fact in the
Guardians of the Galaxy movie so I'll
say John Wick I feel like her character
would fit in the John Wick Universe in
the Mission Impossible movies have
always had eccentricity but it's
generally been around the tech you know
like that that's the crazy stuff her
character's face is painted like a mime
and she fights with a sword if we find
out at a point that the John Wick movies
inspired that character I would not be
the least bit surprised I feel like this
video will be 37 minutes long if I talk
about every character in the film
because cashless is actually quite large
ever growing but how's the movie how
does it stack up as a mission impossible
movie how is the action all of which
entertaining because I feel like
everybody who's reviewed Tom Cruise
movies we've all made the joke right
we've all been like oh the movie's on
cruise control because of Tom Cruise see
the joke take the joke it's an easy one
it is cruise control in the very literal
sense find a speed that works push the
button let the machine maintain it
checks the boxes it needs checks the
boxes you want checks the boxes you
expect spy scene involving masks checked
intense exciting automobile Chase
sequences check Tom Cruise doing an
insane stunt for the sake of the Tom
Cruise IP double check oh but most
importantly
in this you can not do without tracking
shot of Tom Cruise hauling ass on foot
great package it it's in the can enjoy
it works especially the action sequence
part the Mission Impossible movies have
always had really incredible automobile
or motorcycle chase action sequences
it's really refreshing to see action
sequences and Chase sequences that feel
this reel that feel this intense whether
it's a Chase sequence or a really
claustrophobic alley fight got to admit
it's entertaining stuff the movie
definitely borrows from a couple of
video games I will say that if it's if I
found out this movie took place right
where Metal Gear Solid 2 ended just
springboarded and dead reckoning part
one I would not doubt it showing once
again that Kojima was decades ahead of
his time but if it isn't that if it's
not Metal Gear Solid 2 it's Uncharted 2.
I mean if video games Do It Best and
video game movies don't you might as
well borrow from video games and put
them in a movie that's not actually a
translation of the video game now there
was a major glaring issue in the movie
The thing that did not work for me at
all really is the villain not the entity
behind the villain I actually thought
that was interesting intriguing I want
to see more of it we will in dead
reckoning part two I imagine but the
main antagonist the person he just came
across as wooden and kind of forced
especially how they have him tie into
Ethan Hunt's pass those like seven
movies deep and right just felt like
between the people chasing Ethan Hunt
and Ethan Hunt trying to stop this thing
you had enough but someone got the idea
yeah we should probably have a person a
face that Ethan Hunt has to go up
against all right we'll quickly ride in
this guy granted it's kind of hard to
judge because this is part one imagine
me watching a movie stopping and halfway
through and be like all right this is
what I think about it it's kind of hard
to think about that but alas here we are
for the third time in about a month and
a half this is the third movie I could
think of in two months that's done the
whole hey this is part one of two kind
of bit kind of getting annoying at this
point I hope it doesn't become the new
trend but Hollywood being Hollywood
Studios being Studios and the trend
Chasers that they are you can totally
see it becoming the new trend point is
some of these elements including but not
limited to the villain that didn't get
so fleshed out in this movie maybe by
the next movie they do get fleshed out
who knows by the end of the next movie
it might be the greatest five-hour epic
spy Espionage Saga I've ever seen in my
life nitpicks aside and the fact that
this franchise at this point does feel
like it is quite literally on cruise
control where in which you find the
formula that works stick to the formula
check the boxes and just proceed forward
it still makes for reliably Kick-Ass
popcorn entertainment it's not as tight
and fleshed out as I feel Mission
Impossible movies have been in the
recent past however it is part one of
two and that's kind of the risk you run
into when you do that with the action
action set pieces and overall fun
eccentric spy I have myself a good
time no I alcohol required or submission
impossible dead reckoning part one have
you seen it what did you think about it
or how do the Mission Impossible movies
rank to you favorite to least favorite I
don't know top five however you want to
do it don't work too hard here whatever
you think comment below let me know and
as always if you like what you've seen
here and you want to see more click
right here to say more
[Music]